some of you guys are familiar with
entertainment at one point he claimed to
be an Orthodox Christian goes to church
twice a week other points he said
Christianity is a weak religion and
Muslims the last True Religion Islam's
last religion so on
then I I saw another Muslim YouTube
channel from I think they're called the
three Muslims and they showed the source
of him openly professing to be uh uh a
Muslim now once we get to this point
it's you're gonna you're gonna have your
mind blown okay so check this out here's
the post of Andrew Tate
openly affirming Islam not just going to
a mosque openly affirming it now here's
what's interesting this is why I'm
Muslim any Christian who believes in
good and understands the true battle
against evil must convert so any
Christian must convert anybody that
understands good and evil okay must
convert okay so be patient indeed the
promise of Allah and then he puts a
verse now now did you guys notice what's
underneath here
best Isaiah Saldivar that that's a
friend of mine he's been on a channel
multiple times Andrew Tate saw this
video
downloaded it
reposted it and said this is the reason
why now because he's basically saying
Christians tolerate too much sin says
Isaac the Methodist Church has ordained
their first drag queen to preach in
their churches and listen to what Isaac
has to say in one of his sermons we are
here to learn and to grow and to
deconstruct and to reimagine what church
can be who church can be for and how
church can feel together it can be a
place unafraid to denounce clear phobia
a place unafraid to name the sin of
racism and to call for an end to notice
he has trouble even speaking right there
the church does not need to deconstruct
Jesus is built the church and the Bible
says the Gates of Hell shall not Prevail
against the church what do you think
about this let me know Down Below in the
comments uh brother you posted a video
of a Christian Creator rebuking
the very thing that you find problematic
with Christianity
how does that make any sense
I understand where he's trying to come
from but you have to look at it further
all right yes this dude who posted this
video up was rebuking
but that's all he was doing
okay and and what Andrew T was
specifically referring to
is the fact that the church even allowed
someone like this to come up there and
speak bro just think about it think
about it where in Islam would you have a
proper
proper Muslims
give a a Podium for someone like this to
speak
I mean yes I know there's places around
the world now where
um people are deviating and they're
they're making
um The Alphabet game and all this stuff
like part of this land and they're
trying to combine all this stuff for a
lot man Allah forgive us in this regard
but
for the most part like
over over 99 of Muslims like they would
not give any floor any little room for
someone like this to say anything like
what they said there so this is like the
real thing like you have a church which
allowed that to happen
and now that the question could be like
oh well you just said that there's Parts
you know parts of people in Islam who
are doing some of the same thing okay
that's fair
but look how many people in Christianity
are doing this that's where the real
question lies and and it doesn't take
much for someone to like really look
into it and just kind of see exactly
what Andrew take was getting at
yeah 100 that's definitely a great point
and I want to actually ex expound on
that a little bit more and add even more
context because from the very conception
of Christianity with Paul going to the
Gentiles meaning the non-jews like the
Romans and preaching his understanding
of Christianity to them what did he do
he renounced a lot of the laws they had
to follow like circumcision and and you
know not drinking and not eating pork
and all these things these prohibitions
he renounced them for for the Romans for
the not in the the non-jews basically
and he actually wrote In the New
Testament something along the paraphrase
but something along the lines of
um basically why why are you mad at me
for giving a lie preaching a lie that
brings people to the truth we're using
Allah to bring people to the truth
essentially
and and James rebuked him rebuked him
actually in the Bible as well for doing
that and who was the the head of the uh
the the temple after Jesus peace be upon
Him left so after that what do you have
you have many different understandings
of
um basically the the Divinity of God you
have like modalism subordinationism
separate uh separationism I think is one
um and and so many other isms dualism
and all these other things and then
eventually trinitarianism which is the
Trinity that they understand nowadays so
Christianity from its very conception
has always been changing and changing
and changing yet people who use the
Bible to
um to what's it called
what's the word I'm looking for
they use the Bible to justify uh slavery
across Atlantic slavery they use the
Bible to do that and and I think more
specifically
um they use the Bible and they said that
when God was punishing Noah he made his
children black
so you have these like insane
insane beliefs that are constantly being
shifted and changed and shifted and
changed all throughout the history of
Christianity
and this is what struck like kind of the
the Renaissance and the the all these
revolutions that happened when people
realized listen I'm reading the Bible
everything the church is saying none of
it's in there
what are they making up and this is just
a continuation of the same Trend that's
been happening for the last like 2000
years
so this is nothing new here I do want to
add before we get back to the video that
that guy seems very kind he seems very
genuine and very respectful
I just hope he you know takes the time
to really reflect on the current state
of Christianity in Christians as a whole
because it's really easy to fall into a
a bias kind of fallacy that I'm this way
and I believe in this and this is
Christianity no one else really applies
um I don't think that's fair especially
when you're looking at Andrew Tate's
point
in the year 100
is there any more in the video left or
is that it yeah we're actually I think
only one third of the way through
oh okay
go ahead bro right so so you're gonna
say hey Christians
tolerate this therefore I'm
converting to Islam while watching a
Christian who doesn't tolerate it
you guys think I'm stupid I'm not stupid
guys I know this
[Music]
now are there some goofy Christian
denominations that that definitely
tolerate some weird stuff yeah and you
know what we do here we we we we say
them those are Goobers
we say that that's stupid
can't do that that's not Christianity
that's something else now what would the
alternative be
if this like what would the alternative
be if this was done in a sect of Islam
what would the alternative be to
delete this person what would the better
thing be yeah let's delete this person
because they're right like no they would
be Muslim apologists saying this is
stupid you can't be a progressive
whatever that person is and right and
again and by the way I covered this
right
saying this is stupid this is not no
this is not necessary
um so I'm confused on how
Tate can see this as the reason for why
like the the sheer irony of saying hey
right I want to yada yada now I'll show
you guys another take on this which I
thought was a w take
before he does I just want to make one
point because I think at this point
inshallah will be very clear than
everything I was saying before Andrew
Tate's not saying this Soul video is the
only reason in my head is the earth that
I'm a Muslim he's looking at society as
a whole Christianity as a whole Islam as
a whole weighing everything that he can
see and he can observe and saying okay
well Islam must be the truth because
they actually value their Traditions
that have stood for the last 1400 years
since the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
Him came and taught them Islam that is
essentially what I believe he is saying
so this it's kind of a straw man the
point just one thing to say this is the
only reason is come on man come on yeah
and I wanted to say too like I want to
agree on the fact that like this this
but the seem genuine as well so I hope
you know like it just kind of looks into
a little further but in terms of
annotate posting this thing like it
probably wasn't Andrew tell you let's be
honest like okay it's Andrew takes
account but like do you really think
annotates like has the time to like be
posting on like a social media account
even if it's his own social media like
he this man has bigger things to do and
he probably has someone working under
him that posted that video so
if anything
if anything it was probably the person
that posted it that kind of made this
error that they wanted to like put
something he probably said something and
then they they probably took it and they
like ran with it and they put it but
like you can't just say like oh this is
it like this is why Andrew Taylor
believes in Islam like you said but it's
it's it's probably not you know if we
were to ask him straight up he's
probably gonna say way more than that
absolutely and he has in other videos
like the the one with Aiden Ross that we
also reacted to most of your problems
could be solved where do I get an
Islamic moment you must become a Muslim
yourself first my friend
and and being a Muslim is not easy
there's a lot to learn it's a long
journey even I'm not a scholar I'm
learning you know most of the problems
you're facing currently with women can
be solved by Islam
really it's very clear there he explains
it in depth that there are many problems
in society that Islam fixes
um and even if you look at like the
problem of promiscuity and dating and
that stuff
for a majority of Christians that's not
something Christianity fixes it's
something Christianity allows because
you have a lot of not every not everyone
but obviously a lot like I'd say the
vast majority of Christians going around
in dating as if the religion allows it
and that's the main difference so and
also you can post a video
where like for example this video
someone can post this video and react to
What a Christian brother is saying and
completely ignore us
because what we're saying to this person
doesn't matter what he's focusing on is
what the Christian's saying likewise
when Andrew Tate or whoever posted it
posted that video they're not focusing
on Isaiah saying I rebuke this
like they could have went out of the way
and found the original video it wouldn't
have really made much of a difference
and I think again it's just kind of
missing the point but um let's just see
you know we're happy with you let's see
what uh what the brother has to say now
I'm sure Allah
um
with regards to uh uh the real reason
that this happened kudos
have a whole lot of like positive things
to say about Islam but kudos to the
Muslims the dot whoever these guys are
that that debated young Don and debated
David wood and all these guys right
kudos to them for at least not being
um
giddy about it like they're very sober
about it they're like yo Tate's not a
leader he needs to not operate from a
position of authority he needs to not
write like kudos to them like they're
very very very sober and that is one
thing that is commendable uh to them if
there's one thing I could say is like
man Elite at least like yo this dude's
not a leader no no no no don't platform
him as a leader done some research on
this and the Articles there's plenty of
them there's a video of him in Dubai
praying in a mosque his friend says that
he's in his new home I told you also the
Madden associate what cancer the legend
is here inshallah his new home and
along with
it
and he might be moving from Romania to
Dubai and pretty popular Muslim
so he's moving from Romania to Dubai or
it is planning on it that he might be
moving that he might be from Romania to
Dubai and pretty popular Muslim
apologists have spoken on this and
confirmed it so I'm going off the words
of Ali dawa this is from the social
media platform I checked many people and
they said it's actual social media
platforms if that is the case I can't
say I'm very surprised that Andrew Tate
has become a Muslim all the stuff that
he was saying about Christianity was
uttering complete nonsense it very
clearly showed that he knew nothing
about Christian which we covered on the
channel complete nonsense and I'm very
sure he'll spin something some way but
at the end of the day I think I know the
reason why he's become a Muslim and it's
not something very secretive it's not
something that he hasn't spoken about
but I think it has to do with polygamy
you guys think I'm stupid I'm not stupid
guys I know this
[Music]
I think in reality when you look at the
stuff that Andrew Tate spoke about one
of the things he spoke about quite a bit
was polygamy and it doesn't take a
rocket scientist to figure out that
Christianity is against polygamy
regardless of what some of the folks in
the comment section might like to say
it's very clear that God from the
beginning created them male and female
in a monogamous relationship and I think
part of the reason that he might be
moving from Romania to the United Arab
Emirates is because the UAE allows for
polygamous are you seeing what's going
on here so I'm not very surprised that
this has taken place as a matter of fact
I'm a bit happy not happy necessary that
he's become a Muslim but I'm happy that
we know where he stands I'm happy that
the typologists aren't going to jump
into my videos and other people's videos
and comment about how great of a
Christian and he's really an Orthodox
Christian and we don't understand him
and he's a misunderstood character and
we need to really accept him into our
Christian fold and not criticize him now
they can't do that because it's very
clear where he stands and if he has
converted to Islam I challenge my
statement if he ever sees any of these
videos Remains the Same I didn't think
he was a Christian in the first place so
my comment was to say that he needs to
repent and actually follow Jesus give
his life to him and it remains to be the
same even if he's a Muslim Andrew you
need to repent leave the gospel not your
version of it not what you want actual
gospel that Jesus preached that the
apostles preached at the New Testament
preaches and become a Christian and that
is my call for everybody else as well
especially those individuals that are
here that are part of just pure red pill
Community thinking that they're finding
purpose in life the greatest purpose you
find in life is in Christ Jesus and if
there's Muslims watching this the call
is the same Jesus claimed to be God the
Quran and Muhammad were wrong about
Jesus look at the facts study the facts
repent and become a Christian we as
Christians love you we pray for you we
want you to come to know Jesus truly the
version of Jesus you have in Islam is
not the version of Jesus that Jesus
spoke about take care God bless you guys
and I will see you next time
well okay first firstly there's a lot to
unpack put it full screen bro yeah okay
there's a lot to unpack virtually I I
think I think that guy is also I think
he's fairly genuine as well he seems
kind and these are the Christians that I
respect because they are respectable I
think they give respect and they're
actually at least they try and stick to
the book there are however like kind of
what the heck did he say moment in that
first and foremost listen Andrew Tate is
a person who can he has a lot of money
Allah Mubarak he was you know he was he
had the ability at least again with a
lot of different women why on Earth
would he want to get married
to a limit limitation of four
that doesn't make sense he also is a
person
who says that even Christians and we
discussed this earlier first and
foremost that Christianity is not
something that really enforces their
values and Views and that he was only a
Christian because that was the the
dominant religion of Romania he didn't
he didn't say I'm a Christian because I
truly believe in this and not and so on
and so forth he was a Christian because
that was the dominant power in uh
religious power in Romania so to say
that he only moved there the only reason
is because the polygeny Habibi yeah
Habibi he could have a 20 000 women
night after night after night
if you wanted to in Romania and not have
to marry any of them I so like and also
if you look at Abraham he had two wives
if you look at uh Solomon in the Bible
you had 300 wives it's like why are you
acting like there's no such thing as as
a multitude of wives in in the Bible at
all that is so not the case
and bro like
man I just want to say because
he was trying to like say everything
like dead on that's it like you knew
everything that he was talking about and
like again it's it's like you said
took my hat off to him for doing that
because that's uh you know sticking by
the book and he's not one he's not one
you know like we we should we should
look at what
Jesus said right the actual gospel but
the thing is is that the actual gospel
can't be found the actual gospel it's
been it's been lost
what we have today is just like this
butchering of things that we don't even
know what's real what's not real what
what Jesus peace be upon him said and
what he didn't say it's like the book
that you showed me bro the book where
you have the actual New Testament
Scholars
yeah they looked at it and they said
okay this is what he said this is what
he might have said this is what he
definitely didn't say
show them bro let them have it
this is the book there it is let me flip
my camera just for this let me put my
camera just for this here we go boom I
look uglier but you can read the book
The Five Guys didn't change anything bro
hi baby Allah bless you the five gospels
by the Jesus seminar it has a multitude
of New Testament Scholars
and you see there's there's a big a bit
of gray a bit of black a bit of pink so
they put in uh Red Letters things Jesus
most likely said they put in pink
letters like here things he probably
said they put in Gray letters like here
things he probably didn't say and they
put in bold black things Jesus
definitely did not say and when you flip
through the book
uh get the get the book closer to the
middle but they can't see the book uh uh
okay so when you flip through the book
what's the the majority it's mostly
black bro mostly black which means most
of the things in the New Testament and
to be fair it's the five gospels
including the Gospel of Thomas which
Christians don't see as canonical
um mainly because it doesn't talk about
the crucifixion or resurrection of Jesus
but
um you can see most of the things that
are narrated are have nothing to do with
Jesus and they're not what Jesus said
according to New Testament Scholars and
if you look at uh someone like I know
Christians maybe don't like bar Ehrman
but he is a new testament scholar he's
done debates with other New Testament
Scholars you can go watch those he
mentions that there's a unanimous
agreement there's the unanimous opinion
that the The Originals will not be found
in New Testament Scholars stopped using
the term Originals original gospels
because they know it will not be found
he's right we should
we should be following what Jesus peace
be upon him was actually preaching but
the thing is is that again what he
originally preached has been altered it
can no longer be found we don't know
exactly what he was saying during that
time but what we didn't know
is exactly what the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him said and it's he's
literally saying it that this is what
Allah is saying that every single
Prophet has been preaching these same
exact thing and every time there's an
alteration that's when God comes back
and resend the message brings it back
and that's why if you look at it it's
like okay if listen if Christianity if
Christianity was
the final
religion if Christianity was exactly
what it was supposed to be if it truly
is Christianity it was truly supposed to
accept Jesus as our savior
and repent to him and all this stuff
why is it
that there has been a
final
Testament
right the final testament which is the
Quran the final religion which is Islam
and it preaches the exact same message
that all the abrahamic faiths
have been preaching from the beginning
except without alteration
I mean come on come on bro 100 and I
think as an additive I want to add a
question
Islam very clearly deals with
Christianity it does in the Quran very
clearly deals with Christianity Judaism
polytheism basically every
mainstream understanding of life that
exists I'd say every understanding of
life it deals with it in some way
Christianity has no explanation for
Islam other than it was just the devil
the work of the devil trying to misguide
people okay they have nothing concrete
nothing solid as an argument against
Islam or against the prophet peace upon
them even when you look at the Bible
like in Deuteronomy I think it's 23 I'm
not sure but when you look at
Deuteronomy it says that essentially
gives a criteria that you can tell if a
prophet is a true Prophet by his
prophecies so you're going to tell me
that's in the Bible and then God's gonna
allow a man to come to make like
hundreds of prophecies and basically all
of them come true
and then we still have to reject him as
a prophet even though in the Bible it
says if his prophecies are true then
he's a true Prophet he's spoken the
truth come on there's there's many many
shortcomings but I would love to talk to
one of these or both of these guys
um on the podcast or if they don't want
to talk in public we can do in private
as well because they do seem very
genuine inshallah and I think the last
thing that I want to say
in regards to
um Christianity as a whole in my
experience this is my experience okay
it's not the 100 the truth
um that that I would say right but from
what I noticed is that most Christians
right they'll say that they're Christian
and they'll stick to that they'll stand
by that yeah
because they're just attached they're
attached to it and it is the ego the ego
attachment and they can't let go of the
ego they can't submit the ego fully and
actually submit themselves yeah like 100
percent
again and I say that from my experience
though yeah because every every
Christian that I've come across even
myself when I was Christian like
they don't submit I didn't submit bro I
can't say I ever fully submitted to God
it's like yeah I had we all had those
moments where like we you know things
times are getting really rough we feel
really low and we get into those moments
we're like oh
um we feel more humble and we're getting
closer to God but it's it's not until
you fully submit yourself
that you really
get close to God really experience God
and that really only happens
when you practice
as a Muslim
why because it's it's the exact proper
guidelines right as a Christian there
aren't really the guidelines
you know like okay they might argue you
might say oh no there are there's in the
book this is listen bro like
as Christians they really only pray
like when
like Sunday service maybe oh I'm about
to eat let me say prayer before I eat
um maybe before going to sleep or
something like that or maybe they might
only pray like when times are hard and
they want to ask for like things to be
easier or help or or something like this
right
you can't you can't fully connect with a
gun
if that's how you're playing like again
like this is
this is not
I don't know I feel like if I keep going
it's just redundant so I'm just gonna
keep it there again my experience with
the Christians that I've come into
contact with with myself as I was a
Christian
and uh just something to take into
consideration
and with that being said